el proceso más importante del sitio se
llaman los indígenas a la discusión que
llegó al supremo tribunal sobre la
demarcación de sus tierras una pelea que
se agudizó desde que llegó ya y el
bolsón ar en su segundo día como
presidente dio el primer golpe dejar en
manos del ministerio de agricultura que
tradicionalmente apoyó a los empresarios
agrícolas la decisión de que tierras
pertenecen a los indígenas su argumento
era el de los ruralistas la indicación
por el tamaño del territorio ancestral
más del 15 por ciento del territorio
nacional está demarcado como tierra
indígena y quilombolas menos de un
millón de personas vivían en estos
lugares verdaderamente aislados de
brazil explotados y manipulados por las
ong integremos juntos a estos ciudadanos
y valoremos a todos los brasileños en
menos de un año llegó la primera
denuncia ante la cpi contra bolsonaro
acusándolo de genocidio y ecocidio y
sería sería fundamental llevar ante los
organismos internacionales cuán
intolerables es el escenario que
bolsonaro estableció en el país de una
incitación a la violencia que puede
llevar al exterminio de los pueblos
indígenas
house términos indígenas pero bolsonaro
continuó con una serie de proyectos
legislativos el primero para permitir la
minería en tierras indígenas y otros
para impulsar la ganadería y grandes
cultivos agrícolas principalmente en la
amazonía
en nuestro territorio está muy amenazado
por la minería y la tala
madereros
vienen y quieren destruirlo todo
destruir lo que es nuestro nuestra
riqueza que da la pelea por la
demarcación de tierras aumentó desde
febrero de 2021 cuando dos aliados de
bolsonaro asumieron las presidencias de
la cámara y el senado desde entonces en
el congreso han avanzado proyectos
ruralistas que le dan tierras a
madereros y mineros a pesar de que los
indígenas las reclaman como propias